en mykolaiv se mira con muchísima
atención lo que sucede a pocos
kilómetros de aquí solamente a 50 se
encuentra la ciudad de gerson una de las
primeras ciudades sino la primera en
caer en manos del control del gobierno
ruso que ha ido imponiendo su voluntad y
marcando el ritmo en esta ciudad a
partir de este fin de semana ya empieza
a imponerse la utilización del rublo
como moneda local y se habla de un
referéndum en el cual la población
tendría que decidir si hace parte de esa
órbita del gobierno de moscú tal como
sucedió en crimea en el 2014 allí más de
la mitad de la población que se ha
quedado pero un sector de ellas sigue
tratando de imponerse de protestar de
salir a las calles con todas las
dificultades se ha conocido de que el
internet está bloqueado las
comunicaciones con esa región siguen
siendo o cada vez son más difíciles esto
hace que aquí en la población de
mykolaiv se mire con mucha atención y
con mucha esperanza en esa presión que
hacen las fuerzas sugeridas para detener
avance del ejército ruso ayer el comando
central de la defensa ucraniana decía
que los rusos están buscando debilidades
dentro de los frentes o la defensa
ucraniana sin embargo ellos se sostienen
y la ciudad trata de volver a su
normalidad a pesar de las dificultades
como la falta de agua